the view from primrose hill in london's
regions park Misha's guide for the day
is guy hills he's doing his morning run
and as always he's dressed in style not
too bad I'm me sorry guys pleasure to
meet you you're very good in shaver
Hills works as a fashion designer that's
why he even dresses up for sports from
primrose hill we walked to his house
where he lives with his wife and three
children several celebrities among the
model kate moss and chef jamie oliver
lived nearby hills goes off to get
changed he'll do that more than once
today fashion is his life mache gets a
new jacket too when we last met hills in
2010 he appeared in classic british
style we watch that report in his
basement workshop
back then a so called tweed run bike
door was making its way through London
some 400 riders coasted through the city
dressed in authentic tweed Hills had
just founded the fashion label dashing
tweeds and was convinced of the merits
of the woolen fabric how has your own
brand changed in the last three years
what happened um well we're getting
taken seriously I'm to begin with it was
just about making things I wanted for
myself and really really fun things and
now we're working lots of british mills
but always wet with british mills but
but we've been winning some awards and
people realizing that there's a whole
movement people actually want to buy
quality fabrics this is the canal right
behind dealers house he owns a rowing
boat an unusual way to get around in
London Hills loves the unconventional
Camden Lock is one of London's most
famous markets it's full of interesting
clothes and other curiosities Hills
wants to show Mischa a store where you
can buy old 78s he's brought along his
own gramophone let us play really well
yeah Sammy's music now people never
taken really player
do you think like the modern world has
lost like the real style no I just think
the people too busy and I think that
whole thing about the fast fast fashion
and the fact that close have made
mass-produced and people don't care
about them I think that's that's the
thing the journey through London
continues this time by taxi and sporty
new outfits London has over eight
million residents for more than any
other city in the EU famous sites like
trafalgar square tower bridge and
Buckingham Palace attracts some 14
million tourists to the city each year
the legendary Savile Row famous for its
many high-class taylors hill supplies
many of them with his own tweed fabrics
but he shops here himself too he gets a
new blazer jacket at welch and Jeffrey's
naturally it's made out of his own
material and as much to his taste he
wears it for the next part of our tour
after fashion Hills next big passion is
photography he takes mission to Somerset
House a museum overlooking the river
thames to show him one of his idols the
work of a bean bloomin fetch is
currently on display here the german
photographer revolutionized fashion
photography in the 1940s and 50s misha
and is host head back to the house for
another change of clothes Hills can't
imagine living in any other city you can
never get bored of London that's for
sure sir yes last thing I really like
about London just in general is that
there's always a leash there's an
underground hobby or you know element of
individuals next up is libertine one of
the city's hippest clubs here londoners
are celebrating the great gatsby an
early summer blockbuster in 20 style
how do you like parties like that where
everybody like money dresses up I think
it's great having everyone first of all
the time like like food and the world
would be a happier place and so guy
Hills happily winds down his day
surrounded by great people dressed like
a gentleman and with a good drink in his
hand